marun [ __ ] petit orange et dans que me
voici compagnons du mondial mais aussi
de la fausse itron hidalgo de l'été 92
je suis peut être un bon présage pour
notre ami michel hidalgo lui aussi n'a
pris tôt je pouvais être un formidable
avant-centre puisque je mesure plus de
15 mètres et que je ne manque pas d'air
1500 mètres cubes très exactement moi
qui y ai beaucoup de chance puisque cet
été des centaines de chaînes de
télévision diront au monde entier que
petit torrent gêne à vannes rittaud est
un amoureux du football
en oubliant de préciser et je le
regrette que je suis né dans une valve
régions l'auvergne
c'est pourquoi je suis tout
particulièrement heureux de faire ce
soir ma première apparition à la
télévision régionale car ces deux
cournot que 30 reproduction fidèle de ce
que je suis c'est à dire une mascotte
partiront pour les quatre coins du monde
et notamment l'espagne où je vous donne
rendez vous et puis soit dit en passant
sachez que j'ai un petit faible pour la
bande à platini rien étonnant n'est ce
pas puisque c'est en france que j'ai vu
le jour